for his contributions to Modern render
farm management and system design is
exemplified in the scheduling
architectures of Q3 and plow the academy
presents a technical Achievement Award
to
Matt Chambers
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of people to think when you ride a
render Farm everyone's involved
but first I'd like to thank the academy
for this award
render Farms were basically in a session
of mine for a decade of my life so this
award means a great deal to me
next I'd like to thank Chris June and
Rob Brado for entrusting something so
critical to production
to a young Wrangler with less than a
year experience in the industry it's
probably a momentary lapse of judgment
on their end
but in a way Chris and Rob gave me my
big break in Hollywood if there is such
a thing for a software developer and
clear there is because I'm up here right
now
I also want to thank John Welborn Blair
zajac Ben dines Brian Wong who are
instrumental in the development of Q3 as
well as Jordan Souls Garrick McLaughlin
and Julie groll for their support we're
rolling out Q3 into production
um I want to give special thanks to the
entire imageworks PST PST Department the
Wranglers but especially Andrea pace for
hiring me even though I wore a suit to
my interview
I knew I was overdressed when while
waiting in the lobby someone came into
work wearing a bathrobe and slippers
and from wedding digital I'd like to
thank Justin rizzaro Graham demix Andy
Wright and Bill Ryder if there was a
team that was going to pull off getting
the largest and most complex rent a farm
in history onto this crazy new system
called plow it was that team
their talent and their passion and
superhuman efforts made what was
considered Impossible by many not only
possible but also really fun as well
Alas and certainly not least I'd like to
thank my wonderful wife Vanessa for her
support an incredible amount of patience
over the years while I brought all this
work home with me I couldn't have done
it without her
and I also want to give a shout out to
my kids Luke and Lila who are from named
after characters in Friday Night Lights
which use the rain bar so we've come
full circle
thank you
[Music]